so let's think a little bit about how
you might decide where you want to go to
college and the first thing I'll remind
you because this can oftentimes be a
pretty stressful decision is that there
is no right decision you just need to
make the decision right now what do I
mean by that is there are plenty of
great colleges and universities and
community colleges and if you go to them
with an attitude of hey I'm going to
take advantage of what this campus what
this program has to offer I'm going to
put myself out of my comfort zone I'm
going to sign up for clubs I'm going to
introduce myself to people I'm going to
try to get internships I'm going to try
to join co-op programs I'm going to try
to get to know my professors you'll
probably do pretty well pretty much as
long as you go to one of these
reasonable places now on the other hand
you could go to some of the fanciest
colleges on the planet but if you go
there a little bit afraid to step out of
your comfort zone if you're a little bit
passive about your education you kind of
just let the education happen to you as
opposed to you happening to the
education then it might not be great or
it just might not be a great fit for you
for for whatever reason so it's not
about someplace being perfect it's about
what you bring to it now with that said
there probably are certain types of
places that you might Thrive more than
others so the first thing and we talk
about this in other videos you can look
at the cost of of different options and
always keep in mind things like
financial aid don't just look at the
sticker costs sometimes the financial
aid and some of the most expensive
universities is the most significant
financial aid so definitely take a look
at that but it's not just about cost
it's also about benefit talk to a lot of
folks especially students who are at
that program ideally people who are
recent graduates who or who graduated
maybe five or ten years ago and ask them
about both their career opportunities
any regrets they might have whether what
what they thought was going to it
happened was it better than expected was
it worse than expected and also about
their experience there could be two
folks who end up in a similar place
career-wise and money-wise but one might
say yeah you know my four years of
college really it wasn't really working
out for me it wasn't really weren't
really great years and there could be
someone else that says well you know
those are some of the best years of my
life
I met some of my best friends I was so
stimulated uh Etc so that has to be part
of the equation too we're not living
just to uh make money and and have a job
and pay bills now that's important too
uh but it's also about having an
experience in life that you think might
be fulfilling and make you a better
person in a lot of ways now your general
options are going to be obviously you
could go to four-year College four-year
colleges you'll often have your in-state
colleges which will tend to have lower
tuition and then you might have the
private colleges which will have tend to
have higher tuition but once again keep
in mind things like financial aid don't
write off an expensive University
without looking a little bit into how
they give financial aid and whether you
might be able to get a pretty good
financial aid package now you also have
associate programs community colleges
these might be really great options the
cost can be significantly lower
especially because they're close to home
maybe you live at home and in many cases
you can go into one of those programs
and sometimes get a great job coming out
of them or you can transfer for to a
four-year degree and and save some money
in in the process and for at least those
those first two years
the one thing I will uh tell you to be a
little bit wary of are what I would and
I don't want to say you know all
for-profit universities are bad or good
or Etc but when you're looking at
colleges and Associate programs that
that that are for profit so they aren't
not-for-profit organizations they're
owned by a corporation
you just have to be a little bit wary
about what their motivations are
especially many times they'll have a lot
of marketing they'll really talk about
all of the things that they're doing for
their students but you need to ask the
hard questions to make sure that those
outcomes are really happening I'll tell
you a story when I used to work at an
investment fund we once talked to a
publicly traded company that um ran some
of these associate programs and I have
to tell you you know they seem very
focused on what their marketing costs
were and how long the students needed to
spend at their campus or their online
program in order for them to collect the
government grants
um but they really didn't have great
outcomes and so this was a situation
where their motivation and I'm not
saying this is going to be the case for
all for-profit universities but their
motivation was definitely hey you know
we want to Market as aggressively as
possible get people through the door
collect some of that government grant
money and then yeah you know hopefully
something good happens to them
afterwards but they didn't seem as
focused there and it's also not to say
that all not-for-profit universities are
perfect either similarly you have to
really scrutinize they might give you
some numbers about hey our average
graduate does this or the average
graduate with a job gets this but you
have to say well how many of them get a
job and how quickly do they get a job I
would recommend actually talking to real
people recent graduates seniors looking
to get a job to see if those outcomes
really hold up or did they have to
really hustle for them in ways that
maybe the college didn't support them
that much that's real real information
so what I would recommend
keep a reasonable number of options some
that might be a little bit more of a
stretch some that might be your backup
very affordable you know they're going
to be but then before you make the
decision definitely visit the campus see
how it feels talk to people on the
campus see if it resonates their
experience seems like something you'd
want and also talk to as many people as
possible
especially recent grads or seniors might
that might be looking for a job and
don't be afraid to ask what I would call
slightly impolite questions which is
like how much money are you making are
you stressed about it are you making
what you thought you were how much did
the school help you with career
placement do you think you would have
gotten this job if uh you you went
someplace else uh do you think do you
wish you majored in something else do
you have any
Etc so
um you have your future in front of you
just ask really really good questions of
a lot of folks be a little bit nosy
don't always accept what people tell you
especially the universities at face
value double check for yourself and then
you'll probably be in pretty good shape